question is
hey lex i was wondering how you managed
to remain optimistic in the face of
adversity
when you encounter hostile people that
don't want to even consider offering
constructive criticism
and would rather try to tear you down
and force their ideology
i find pieces of hope for short periods
of time
and then they fade after i see the
arguments surrounding whatever brought
about hope to begin with
i guess to put it simply how do you hold
on to hope
and optimism thank you for the question
there's probably a lot to be said about
this but i'll try to keep it brief
and simple
i tried to ignore the noise of the world
the the bickering of the moment
i find that if you give yourself a
chance to see how amazing people are
that those people will reveal themselves
to be amazing
that you will see it
that if you give yourself a chance to
see it you will see it
i see it and i see
gratitude for how amazing things are and
optimism for how much even better
things could be as a kind of superpower
it makes life exciting in a way that
first is just fun to live
and two from just a productivity
perspective
as an engineer or anybody who creates
anything
it's fuel to create
i believe that to create new things
and especially for things that others
will say is not possible to create
i find that optimism is a necessary
precondition
to give you the energy the fuel the
drive the inspiration to go for
months for years to carry the fire of
belief
that that's where that optimism truly is
a superpower that enables that kind of
perseverance
so i think the most important thing is
it makes life
more exciting and fun and
it's a good productivity hack it's the
second thing
you also asked how so i try to my
personal life
and uh the influences i take in the
books i read and
and the people i talk to i try to
surround myself with people that are
also
full of optimism and in general i'm uh
unapologetically a fan of a lot of
people
especially sort of big thinkers wild
engineers and scientists and creators of
all walks of life
people that shine in ways that
um surprise me or excite me
there's really thousands to be honest
just off the top of my head
even people i talked on this podcast
chris lattner
always brings a smile to my face one of
the greatest engineers of the world
jim kellers from that ilk as well though
slightly different personalities but
also
inspires me makes me smile such a deep
and kind and brilliant human being
along that line of engineers elon musk
of course also the embodiment
of optimism about this world uh
is an inspiration and then uh
maybe down the dimension of more wild
even george hotz
with a chaotic style of thinking
that's very different than my own but
one that i find just
inspiring of course joe rogan
for me has been for many years a kind of
example of somebody who doesn't take
themselves too seriously
like he's been for a lot of people he
has been for me
a uh role model for
a successful life that's not full of
jealousy and kind of derision
but it's more being supportive of others
being a fan of all this all those kinds
of things
i mean on the darker side dan carlin of
course
you don't often think of him as
optimistic but i truly think he's
optimistic
uh he's just been so deeply
soaking in the muck the darkness
of human history that i think sometimes
the thing he
talks about come off as
as deeply cynical about the future of
human civilization but they're not
there's a shining optimism to him and um
i wasn't in my conversation with him
even though his words were saying that
he's not always optimistic
i think his heart his spirit was clearly
optimistic
there's a hope for us in him
and uh at least to me and that's that's
what i see nice
to me that hope glows pretty bright in
in the stuff that he creates and the
passion that he has for human history
and of course the scientists stephen
will from
uh on the computer science side
i can't tell you how much i love
cellular automata sean carroll
the way he loves everything about
physics is incredible communicator eric
weinstein the way he
loves everything geometrical shapes
of all things whether they're
mathematical or
whether they're connected to physics
just his loves for symmetry
asymmetry for topology for the weird
curvature of
things in the visible dimensions of
space-time or the invisible ones
and that's just sticking to people i've
talked to on this uh podcast of course
joshua bach
whose flow of consciousness is full of
so much brilliance it breaks my brain
anytime i try to process it
my commodore 64 brain takes in his uh
pentium i don't know what the analogy is
but it always breaks my brain
i'm especially inspired by the creations
of software engineers for example
because there's an
inherent optimism to the creative
process
a lot of people in the cryptocurrency
space like vitalik buterin
is a constant inspiration he just goes
on and on
and of course the hundreds probably
thousands of dead folks from nietzsche
dostoevsky freud
young camus hasse
kerouac everybody i mean
i just kind of feel like i exist in this
world of people
that are excited about the future
and then of course the noise of the
world
that is lost in the bickering of the
moment can seep in
and that's where a kind of meditation
comes in
i don't fully ignore it i think
that's kind of running away from the
world
in a way that i don't find constructive
at least at this time in my life
i i just take it in but i don't let it
linger
if there is any kind of harshness or
trolling or just maybe destructive
criticism
i try to pick from it pieces
that i can use to grow to inspire me and
let the rest go
and that's the kind of muscle you have
to build
and every once in a while just
disconnect from it all and
and recharge the mind in a way from
just simple silence of
nature
you